encore là là là
voilà
pata pata pas ap ap ap ap ap ap ah bah
ça y est il ya là plus ses propres
sabrina sabrina ça y est j'ai ramassé
tous les papiers qui étaient dans le
jardin
bravo casimir tu peux être fier de toi
c'est très important de garder propres
les endroits dans lesquels on vit c'est
vrai je peux être fier de moi bien sûr
casimir tu peux être fier de toi tous
ceux qui finissent un travail peuvent
être fiers d'eux haha je suis fier de
moi je suis fier de moi je suis fier de
moi je suis très fier de moi je vais
même d'offrir une récompense
tu peux choisir le cadeau que tu veux
parmi les jouets qui sont autour ou dans
ma boutique
c'est vrai le cadeau que je vaux celui
que tu préfères ses premiers jeux
musique
voyons
stark ça oui
je
bon
tu fais ça m'a passé n'a pas ça non ça
peut-être non c'est pas bon
bonjour sabrina bonjour factor voilà
votre com en a je crois que les enfants
du jardin vont être contents de se jouer
à pas moins
je suis bien content contre avion dès
qu'un patient à rome
posez-les et là je les mettrais dans le
coup à détruire un peu plus tard merci
beaucoup
bon ben on voit et à bientôt pour sûr ça
enfin des facteurs ou web magnifique
merci beaucoup au revoir merci encore
je me dis aux formidables sabrina
sabrina ça y est j'ai trouvé le cadeau
que je veux
anon casimir ce n'est pas possible tu
veux ça oui c'est vraiment le seul
cadeau que je veux c'est terrible je ne
sais pas comment t'expliquer c'est le
seul cadeau que je ne peux pas te donner
il ne fait pas partie des jeunes la
boutique il est destiné aux enfants qui
viennent dans le jardin en mai m
pourtant qui m'avait bien dit que je
pouvais choisir n'importe quel cadeau à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur de la
boutique
c'est vrai je ne peux pas dire le
contraire je mets en commande et un
autre pour les enfants du jardin
je t'ai fait une promesse tu peux
prendre ton cas de mercy sabrina part je
suis tellement content tu sais moi je
suis si content c'est formidable mais
dis moi tu que vous ne pourrez pas
prendre cette chose rouge qui est à
l'intérieur
qu'est ce que tu veux dire oui là c'est
cette cette approche aux roses qui est
là si tu veux je peux l'acheter moi même
ne t'inquiète pas qu à gémir je m'en
charge et je suis ravi que tu es trouver
le cadeau dont il avait le plus envie
pas oui vraiment merci sabrina merci or
c'est là la plus belle boîte projet
jamais vu
quelle belle boîte
[Musique]